[Musique]
un véritable jardin d'éden au coeur de
la ferme de gally potager ruche et
poulaillers une micro ferme pédagogique
pour favoriser le lien entre ville et
nature c'est de sensibiliser des gens
très largement à l'agriculture urbaine
ou au final les particuliers peuvent
jouer un rôle dans cette agriculture et
en fait chacun est en mesure de de
produire ses propres fruits et légumes
sur son balcon sont un terreau à sous ou
son jardin ont fait germer une petite
graine dans la tête des gens que c'est
possible de produire des fruits et
légumes en ville une grande fleur
dessiné au sol regroupe les différentes
techniques à découvrir spirale de
plantes aromatiques culture en lasagnes
ou paillage chaque pétale a sa
spécialité
mais pour les plus petits espaces c'est
derrière qu'il faut regarder une tour de
pommes de terre et réaliser chez soi
même sur un balcon
on a effectué une première couche de
terreau dans lequel dans laquelle on a
planté nos pommes de terre ensuite les
pommes de terre ont germé elles ont
commencé à pousser au fur et à mesure
que la plante pousse à on a rajouté des
couches de terreau elles sont montées
jusqu'ici bon là on va s'arrêter là on
va laisser la plante pousser encore un
petit peu et les pommes de terre pour
apparaître sur toute la hauteur de la
structure
un dernier pétales sera créée autour des
plantes mellifères qui fleurissent en
automne et en hiver
lorenzo aura besoin d'être cet été pour
le réaliser chacun est invité à mettre
la main à la pâte ou plutôt à la terre